foreign
[Music]
we're incredibly excited to announce the
biggest lithium Refinery I uh one of the
biggest lesson refiners in the world uh
location that will be able to uh we
expect produce lithium for about a
million vehicles and uh
uh produce more Bachelor grade lithium
than the rest of North American refining
capacity combined so I'd like to
introduce some people here
um let's see thank you
hello everybody this is a historic day
for Nueces County I'm the Nueces County
Judge Connie Scott I'm so excited to be
here
um this 380. thank you
this investment into our community will
provide jobs and bring our young people
back after they get their degrees and be
able to go to work here buy a home and
raise their families here and we're so
excited to be a very small part of this
I'd like to introduce a few people that
are here that were instrumental in
helping to get this organized and moving
it took a lot of people so we just want
to say thank you to our Austin
delegation that obviously because it's
May they're up in Austin and legislative
they could not be here chairman Todd
Hunter representative April Herrero
Senator Juan Chewie hinojosa and then
we'd like to thank our Robstown Economic
Development Corporation our our regional
economic development course Corporation
our South Texas Water Authority and then
last but certainly not least all of my
Commissioners quarter here commissioner
Hernandez commissioner modes who
represents this area commissioner
Gonzalez and commissioner
thank you thank you governor for being a
governor who has made the state the best
place in the country to do business
thank you Mr musk for your investment
into this community your forethought and
everything we appreciate you we look
forward to many more Endeavors with you
thank you again
thank you so much Judge Scott we we
couldn't be more thrilled to be here my
name is Rohan Patel from the Tesla team
and Judge Scott did all the thank yous
but I just want to reiterate one in
particular and that's to the Robstown
ISD that local school district is just
awesome
and they've made us feel so welcome
thank you to Judge Scott for that
welcome and I want to introduce a friend
of mine Dr Kathleen Hogan who is the
under secretary at the U.S department of
energy Dr Hogan
thank you so much and uh thank you all
for having me here uh as well I just
want to add my words to what an exciting
day this is uh to Mark a groundbreaking
for this first a kind of investment uh
here in our domestic supply chain uh in
this country you know it's great to see
uh what companies like Tesla is doing
you know they've been a leader in the EV
space now for such a long time uh and
now they're being an amazing leader on
building out the clean energy supply
chain here in this country uh which is
uh what we're going to be seeing more
and more of as we move out with uh the
the bipartisan infrastructure law and
other incentives uh put forth uh through
our invest in America agenda so just an
amazing period of time but let's really
talk about this project what does it
mean it means jobs it means Innovation
Innovative process processes and it
really means as we look more
holistically across the country a secure
domestic supply chain as we move out on
this clean energy economy and really uh
it's a secure Energy Future uh really
nationally but when you look here uh and
all of the work that's going to go on
the other important thing is the
workforce I mean it's just amazing to
see the jobs that are going to be here
the skilled jobs that are going to be
here we talk in uh in DC about the
muscle we need to build out around U.S
manufacturing and where is the muscle
the muscles in the workforce uh and the
and that muscle is going to be here
leveraging uh so much of what you can
already do and uh and the capabilities
of the young people that will be coming
through all of your uh training and and
other programs so very very exciting so
I just really again want to say thank
you to Tesla thank you uh to the
governor of Texas and thank you to the
county of newness what an amazing event
so thank you
thank you Dr Hogan
I don't think the next speaker needs any
introduction Governor Greg Abbott
[Applause]
how did Nueces County
this is a great day for Nueces County
you may remember I was here about a
month or two ago and I was talking about
the way that you're going to see a wave
of jobs coming to Corpus Christi in
Nueces County this is just one of many
projects that will be providing those
jobs that will Elevate Corpus Christi
Nueces County Robstown the entire area
far much more congratulations on this
big success
[Applause]
I want to say congratulations to Connie
Scott this is a great day for Nueces
County Dr Hogan thank you for being a
part of this it means a whole lot to
have you here uh congratulations and
thank you to uh Robstown ISD who all
here is with Robstown ISD wave your hand
there you go
a a key part of the way the economic
development Works in this state thank
you for leaning forward into this
project uh that's not just good for jobs
but it's good for the entire future of
the state great decision on this uh to
bring this Landmark facility here this
facility fits within exactly what we are
trying to achieve in Texas with regard
to Economic Development economic
development is a team project takes
County leaders city leaders ISD leaders
committee leaders and I applaud all of
the leaders to achieve our goal Texas
wants to be able to be self-reliant not
dependent upon any foreign hostile
Nation for what we need
we need lithium for the phone you have
in your hands for the batteries that
will be in Tesla trucks for other
purposes Texas wants to be able to
increase our ability to refine lithium
you have taken that step with this
project today is coming to reality Texas
is going to be more self-reliant today
than we were yesterday because of the
leadership right here in Nueces County
Texas
and of course we would not be here but
for the vision the hard work and the
commitment of Elon Musk and Tesla give
it up for Tesla in Elon Musk
Elon brought his gigafactory here and he
liked it so much he brought Tesla here
and then the boring company here
spacex's here where's newer link
is partly here
that means the future of newer link will
be right here in the Lone Star State and
and so much more and listen there there
is no greater entrepreneur
in the entire world then Elon Musk we're
proud he calls Texas home
Elon Musk and Tesla are part of the
Texas economic Juggernaut uh you were
talking uh Dr Hogan about the the Texas
economy and so were you Elon so Texas
has we ranked number one in the United
States for the fastest growing economy
of any state in the country last year
Texas added more new jobs than any other
state in America with this project and
more we will maintain our position as
being the number one job generator in
the United States of America
we've been ranked by CEOs as the number
one state for doing business for 19
years in a row the number one state for
exports for 21 years in a row Texas has
won the award for economic development
we are the national champions for
economic development every year that I
have been your Governor we've been
number one for economic development
and because of that the Texas economy
has grown so large our economy is now
2.35 trillion dollars a year when I
became Governor Texas if we were our own
country we would have ranked the 12th
largest economy in the World As We
Gather at Nueces County Today Texas now
has the eighth largest economy in the
entire world thanks in part to help
people right here into Oasis County
Texas
so thank you the leadership here for
everything that you do to create a
platform for a great project like this
thank you for creating a warm and
inviting business climate to attract
businesses to your location as your
Governor I want to come back for many
more ground breakings right here in
Nueces County the location for jobs in
the state of Texas
now before I go right here in front of
this new Tesla Giga truck
I want to present a proclamation from
the state of Texas
two Elon Musk is for the Tesla lithium
refinery
it has several paragraphs of language in
there that I will not take the time to
read to you right now just know that
it's carefully awarded in in recognition
of the role that Tesla plays as well as
their lithium Refinery facility plays in
the future of our state we have great
gratitude for the entire Tesla team and
for Tesla lithium refining to be right
here in Nueces County Texas Elon want
you coming up and let me give this to
you
thank you
thank you so much
[Applause]
well it's super appreciate the the kind
words and uh uh really of hey guys
thanks anyway
okay
um so uh I just want to say that uh uh
Tesla is incredibly appreciative uh for
everything that the state of Texas has
done and that the governor's done thank
you
um and uh we appreciate the support of
the county and and really all from at
every level we've just gotten so much
support so I just want to say thank you
all so
absolutely
um and as you can see we've got the uh
Earth moving equipment or already here
so we're going to begin construction
immediately
um we're aiming to finish construction
uh next year and then reach uh hopefully
full production about a year later
that's that's uh which is very this is
extremely fast by you know normal
standards
um
but that's how we do things so
and um
so as I mentioned earlier the the
capability we're aiming for is
approximately a million Vehicles worth
of uh of battery grade lithium
um but the potential is there to expand
beyond that number as needed
um we intend to continue to use uh
suppliers of lithium so it's not that
testable do do all of it but we thought
uh it's important to address what we
think is as we look ahead a few years a
fundamental choke point in the
advancement of electric vehicles is the
availability of battery grade lithium
and lithium ore itself uh for mining is
actually quite common so lithium is is
actually a very common element on Earth
it's present uh basically in every
country so it's not that there's a
shortage of lithium or to mine but there
is a shortage of uh of it's really heavy
industry uh refinement of of lithium to
to battery grade and Battery grade
lithium actually has to be extremely uh
precise Ultra Pure because if you have
any impurities in lithium it causes
degradation of the battery so the purity
of climates are are extremely high
and uh we've got a number of innovations
that we think will be quite effective in
the refining of lithium that haven't
been done before and maybe that's a good
point to hand it over to Drew yeah
absolutely
um and on the process in particular
Turner why don't you uh give a little
rundown of what we're doing here sure
yeah we're happy to run through it my
name is Turner Caldwell I lead our
battery raw material and recycling
efforts at Tesla
um so speaking to some of the Innovation
that we're going to be pursuing on site
the conventional process and I won't get
too into the weeds
um but it's heavy it's a heavy sulfuric
acid consumer it's a headed sodium
hydroxide consumer and as a result the
byproducts that are produced from that
conventional process are challenging to
manage you end up with a lot of sodium
sulfate that no one really wants here
what we're going to be using are much
more inert reagents we'll be consuming
soda ash sodium carbonate very common
industrial chemical we'll be consuming
lime again very industrial at very
common industrial chemical and it's is a
much more direct route that consumes 20
percent less energy all in it consumes
reagents that are 60 percent less cost
uh costly
um and uh and all in the the production
cost is around 30 percent lower uh on a
unit utic cost basis
um but the real key thing here is that
the byproduct that's produced is is much
more inert it's basically a mix of of
sand and Limestone
um and the team here has been working
really hard on finding beneficial use
opportunities for that that sand and
Limestone to try to feed that into
construction materials so that we end up
with a as a net environmentally uh very
neutral site
yeah and I think one of the great things
about both working on this lithium
Refinery here uh in Corpus uh and the
cathode facility that we have in Austin
is that we see the end-to-end uh impacts
of any decisions we make on the
technical side on how we design the
battery cathode or specify the purity of
the lithium so that we avoid unnecessary
complication along that path the whole
dig it a ditch fill it and dig it again
that tends to happen in the material
supply chain we we are very
intentionally sort of eating our own dog
food as sometimes they say to make sure
that we don't uh hold ourselves to
standards that are unnecessary while
still delivering an awesome end product
and cutting out all the the the
inefficient process steps along the way
in fact we're looking at 30 percent
fewer process steps in this Refinery
than a typical Refinery while still
achieving what we need to uh to to hit
our cathode uh quality and performance
targets
um yeah so some of that is actually
removing some of the purification steps
that you would put in if you were a
standalone lithium producer because
ultimately what matters is impurity
level is in the final product not in the
intermediates that get handed from
supplier to supplier yeah I mean like
the the most efficient form of lithium
to use is lithium hydroxide instead of
we're getting a little technical here
but lithium hydroxide instead of lithium
carbonate but what a lot of um
current industry refining things we'll
do is they'll convert it to lithium
hydroxide then converted to lithium
carbonate then convert it back to
lithium hydroxide that's what we mean by
dig the digital dish they're going to
gain yeah so we wanted to stop that and
just just go straight to high Purity
lithium hydroxide and a couple of points
about you know this location it really
is an ideal location for
um uh us to have this lithium Refinery
both because of the strong Community
sport but also the talent base that's in
Corpus Christi in the room in oil and
gas refining actually is is rarely
applicable to what we're doing here uh
it's close to Austin uh there's a really
good deep water Port so we can bring in
uh the spodium which is The Rock input
to this Refinery from you know all over
North America through an easy path and
it's also directly on rail so we can
also bring in the Rock and the send the
outgoing product VIA Rail so truly an
awesome site with a fantastic Community
Support can't thank you enough and
really excited to get this project in
motion yeah and we do want to emphasize
this is a very sort of a clean a Toyota
sort of alluded to it but a very clean
Refinery uh so it's not like there's
there's no toxic emissions or anything
you could live you could live right in
the in the middle of the refinery and
not suffer in any ill effects so a very
clean uh operation
yeah the
um as we look forward into the future
obviously day one it's designed for this
spodium concentrate it's from Hard Rock
minds but as we start to have recycled
batteries coming back the factory is
designed to be feed flexible and so
we'll be actually processing lithium out
of black mass as well as from Brine and
Clay operations that are also ramping up
in North America and so as we as we view
this site as uh having a major focus on
regionalizing the lithium supply chain
it's all about being feed flexible and
taking advantage of all of those feeds
including manufacturing scrap and
end-of-life batteries yep so a virtuous
circle of battery materials in North
America for North American factories
really excited to set that you know
agenda in motion both in Austin and here
in in Corpus Christi today
great sounds good so
what should we do next oh yes oh yeah
Travelers I think we should break some
ground break some ground great let's
break ground all right
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
here in Corpus Christi we're looking
forward to creating incredible operation
and once again thanks for your support
all right
[Music]